Jim Rassman it's good welcome to
finalizar
that game that is not a game at all so I
asked you bros on Twitter who needs to
be fabulous and you say so yes like I'm
angry looks I needs to be changed
have you ever thought to yourself man I
wish my face was a double-faced that
looks fantastic but yeah I need some
improvement that is [ __ ] weird man
God what else is in need oh my god
have you ever thought man I wish I could
make out with myself of course you do
you're beautiful you do it in the mirror
that's these girls you're a sick man
Kayne you're a sick sick man Wow what
the [ __ ] is wrong with me this should
just be called nightmare generator
don't cry Kanye don't cry you have
yourself
does he always like call himself a king
or a god or something our very first fab
Eliezer has been successful nightmares
nightmares everywhere what Kanye was
doesn't get pissed at anyone everyone
knows that come on
you cannot give me any advice should
have made him into a gay fish yeah okay
what's next is you had it coming man
you can't be hating on the gays with
that psycho phase okay so this guy I'm a
little scared up for various reasons but
he has said in her fab you know it has
he has it in him I don't know why all
right what can we do this okay so first
of all let's be honest this is not very
good so he's gonna have to upgrade it
obey and done doesn't look disfigured at
all already an improvement like I'm
actually doing him a [ __ ] favor here
that's not the point okay so that's what
you would hold now let's do something
about that hair man
my parents no good your app that looks
pretty good I would be very proud if I
were you mr. Putin okay
that's Putin for you you always have a
butt like ready and it's princess one
and it's beautiful
[Applause]
can't believe we're never done Britney
before what the [ __ ] this picture is
probably my favorite favorite picture
ever I feel like she's a fruit I don't
know why it all makes sense now
Britney Spears is in orange why has no
one seen this before my god for some
reason these always turn up very very
disturbing oh my god
I didn't want to put too much effort on
the shirt so that's what we're getting
here but oh my god with him he did what
happy my mother was an orange was
Britney Spears your mom Wow
I found this beautiful picture of Will
Smith and my inspiration is I don't know
that looks weird how about we just add
him as a little friend
I don't know what oh they're singing to
him well let's confirm for the last load
of the Ring let's do our beloved if my
channel gets suspended you know it's
Georgie boy wow that is hot
what am I doing with my life oh my god
whatever look so Cowie though okay
best fabulae Singh ever I'm really
losing my [ __ ] here is a great picture
to finish off with we are starting to
have a faceless beautiful man
all right what should we do with this he
looks so cute
Wow
that doesn't look disturbing at all
that's I'm done I'm done I'm so done
all right first I hope you enjoyed this
episode if you did go ahead and leave a
like I really appreciate you doing that
it means a lot to me that you both share
your support thank you for being
subscribed and thank you for being a bro
see you tomorrow with another video love
your breasts say awesome
[Music]